Dena machete likes living in the center
of Rome although she shakes her head at
the changes in her neighborhood ice
cream shops pubs and fast-food joints
create a constant acoustic assault not
even the music of buskers is redeeming
the district of trust avada has
succumbed to the Roman nightlife and
kick one book I dread every night when
the pubs close their doors people stay
out on the streets after closing time
shouting many young people are drunk
they urinate and throw up below my
windows sometimes I even have to call an
ambulance for them at four in the
morning la cuesta el cuatro del mattino
it's nighttime when Deena really loses
her cool she tries to get the musicians
and revelers outside her apartment to
quiet down but has a hard time
convincing them it's midnight in Rome
and going home is the last thing on
these people's minds what was if I occu
that I'll ruin out how can anybody close
up at one o'clock for most people that's
when the nights just beginning in Qin mo
mean throw go buddy Milan all think the
partygoers have little understanding for
the neighborhood's older residents who
want to turn in for the night Vince
wonky anyone who lives here in downtown
Rome has enough money to buy a quiet
flat somewhere else but many aren't
prepared to move out and young suburban
Romans don't want rowdy revelers on
their own doorstep either they'd rather
party in the city center noise was also
a problem in Milan but residents here
put a stop to revelers keeping them up
all night Julia and Luca set up a
Citizen Action Group that forced City
Hall to pass more stringent laws on
noise pollution you argued over si trova
no leave is through go see the officials
in City Hall understood that the most
important thing is to protect the city
protected from vandalism and graffiti
and keep its public works of art from
being destroyed Dena God secret ah smoke
any port after a night of partying these
people have completely lost control of
themselves bundle exam did logo the to
use decibel meters to bolster their
fight against the noise they say
european union law backs them up in
their battle is eastern Anka Dylan or
European law is on our side it says
residents here have to be informed
before decisions are made that will
radically alter their lives I mean a
neighborhood here has been turned into
something resembling Las Vegas and no
one was even asked about it Seikichi
that any facilities at new laws prohibit
the consumption of food and drink on the
streets of Milan after midnight the aim
is to prevent large gatherings and keep
noise levels down but snack bar owner
Franco Falcone isn't happy the new law
means he can't sell his sandwiches to
party goers and that he says could spell
the end of his business she was a little
one in the morning i'm not allowed to
serve anything it's also illegal to eat
on the streets it's madness it's
destroying 20,000 jobs here in the city
enjoying a gelato on the city streets
was also initially forbidden but even
the peace-loving inner-city residents
thought that was a step too far
authorities reversed the decision and
since then have been trying to take a
more measured approach a nap you patria
TV that the law is aimed more at dinner
kebabs pizzas and bottled beer could be
arrival ice cream was also affected at
first but that was corrected after 48
hours subito nadie le cuento
anyone eating or consuming alcohol in
public is now politely asked to move on
Marco granelli from City Hall thinks the
generational divide is to blame for the
noise problem he increasingly sees it as
a conflict between young people from the
suburbs and elderly residents in the
inner city more dancin yawning before
they lo habian with the chisel we have
to mediate the new rules say that every
public bar in the party districts has to
be closed by three o'clock in the
morning we the police have to protect
the interests of everyone who lives
there but the bottles come out again as
soon as the police are out of sight many
partygoers are determined not to let the
new regulations spoil their night out
this is new log there is nothing really
happening here right now come back at
four when everybody's really drunk some
are even using drugs that's when they
really let their hair down no problemo
senor edina in rome dreams of a good
night's sleep and intends to keep on
fighting for her full 40 winks
you